Transcription: Mandy Vincent
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
La première fois que j’ai rencontré Yanis,
c’était au début des années 2000,
pendant mes études d’orthophonie.
À vrai dire, ce n’est pas lui
que j’ai vu en premier
mais son éducatrice.
Elle revenait tout juste
d’un arrêt de travail
et elle avait le bras en écharpe.
Yanis, lui, je l’ai surtout entendu.
Il faisait une pause
dans une salle à côté.
Il criait fort, très fort
et il sautait à en faire trembler
les murs et vibrer le sol.
Je suis sûr que vous
vous dites que j’exagère.
Mais non.
C’est bien ce qui arrivait
quand Yanis était content.
Cette petite unité d’accueil
dans une vieille maison de village
au parquet ancien a dû
en garder les traces d’ailleurs.
Comme son éducatrice.
Quand Yanis n’allait pas bien
et qu’il rentrait en crise,
il pouvait s’en prendre
aux objets autour de lui,
à lui-même ou aux autres personnes.
Parfois jusqu'à la fracture du bras.
J’ai oublié de préciser
que Yanis avait 17 ans,
un bel ado d’un mètre quatre-vingt environ
et la carrure d’une armoire à glace.
Alors j’avoue, quand je l’ai rencontré
pour la première fois, j’ai flippé.
Vraiment.
Yanis comme Noa,
Valentin, Ludo, est autiste.
Il ne parle pas oralement
et il présente
une déficience intellectuelle.
Certains diraient qu'il cumule.
Surtout si on le regarde
à travers le prisme de ses troubles.
D’ailleurs,
c’est bien de ça dont on parle,
du trouble du spectre de l’autisme
qui se définit par une altération
de la communication sociale
et des particularités
dans le comportement.
Alors, je me suis dit
que si moi, orthophoniste,
je suis spécialiste du langage
et de la communication
et si Yanis ne parle pas et a
un trouble de la communication,
pas besoin d’avoir inventé
l’eau chaude pour se dire
qu’on a peut-être quelque
chose à faire ensemble.
Pourtant, encore aujourd’hui,
des familles doivent se battre
pour que leur enfant soit
adressé en orthophonie
et puisse bénéficier du suivi
dont il a besoin.
« Parce que ma petite dame,
votre enfant n’a pas besoin d’orthophonie.
Il ne parle pas. »
Quand j’y pense, encore aujourd’hui,
je vire au violet betterave
tant ça me met en colère.
Permettez-moi de vous le dire comme ça
mais c’est une sacrée connerie ce truc-là.
Car tout le monde sait
qu’on peut communiquer sans parler.
Un bébé qui ne prononce encore aucun mot
communique avec ses parents,
avec son entourage.
Il sourit, il pointe,
il utilise son corps, ses mains,
les mimiques de son visage,
il pleure.
C'est bien de la communication tout ça.
Mais dans certains cas,
dans l’autisme par exemple,
il peut être nécessaire d’entraîner tôt
ces comportements de communication
et de proposer des systèmes
alternatifs au langage oral.
Mais ça, j'y reviendrai tout à l'heure.
Grâce à Yanis,
j’ai appris à dépasser ma peur
pour affirmer ma place auprès de lui
et j'ai fait de ma colère un moteur.
Quelque temps après
ma rencontre avec Yanis,
est sortie en France une loi,
bien connue des familles
des personnes en situation de handicap.
La loi du 11 février 2005
pour l’égalité des droits et des chances,
la participation et la citoyenneté.
C'est comme ça qu'elle s'appelle.
Cette loi indique entre autres,
que tout enfant a
le droit d’aller à l’école.
Ce n’est pas une fleur
qu’on lui fait à cet enfant autiste,
c’est son droit d’aller à l’école
comme tous les enfants.
Ces enfants autistes,
en âge d’aller à l’école, y vont.
Mais rarement à temps plein,
malheureusement,
et souvent pour travailler
la socialisation.
Or l’école, ce n’est pas seulement
les interactions sociales,
c'est aussi les apprentissages.
Et parmi eux, un apprentissage essentiel
auquel les enfants sont
préparés dès la maternelle
et sur lequel repose
toute la suite de leur scolarité.
Vous voyez de quoi je parle ?
De la lecture.
Oui.
Savoir lire et utiliser l’écrit,
c’est pas mal pour vivre
une vie autonome de citoyen.
Pour apprendre,
raconter des histoires
ou quelque chose que l’on a vécu,
s’informer, s’évader.
Avez-vous déjà pensé à tout ce que
la lecture vous permet de connaître,
de découvrir ?
Si on parle d’égalité des chances,
ça veut dire que cet apprentissage
devrait être accessible à tous.
Et pourtant, dans les guides
ou les formations,
on peut parfois lire que c’est compliqué
pour les enfants autistes,
ce n’est pas prioritaire,
qu’il y a d’autres choses à travailler
et surtout que c’est quasiment
impossible si l’enfant ne parle pas.
Que pour apprendre à lire,
il faut d’abord savoir parler.
Encore.
Ça signifie que cette condition,
ne pas savoir parler, ne pas oraliser,
est considérée comme un obstacle
à pouvoir bénéficier
des mêmes droits que les autres.
« Et ouais, dommage
petit gars, fallait parler. »
Mais ces conditions reposent
sur ce que l’on sait
du développement
chez l’enfant non autiste.
L’enfant au développement ordinaire,
celui qu’on dit normal.
Mais les enfants autistes
présentent des particularités,
des singularités dans leur développement
qui ne suivent pas un chemin tout tracé,
un chemin standard.
Pourquoi alors devrions-nous
leur imposer nos repères, nos normes ?
Qu’est-ce qui fait que moi,
je devrais imposer,
choisir un chemin qui prendrait
le risque de ne pas lui convenir ?
Et de constater que : « C’ est bête.
Il n’y arrive pas, cet enfant ».
Et si, plutôt que de voir
des supposées incapacités,
je me questionnais sur la manière dont
j’enseigne quelque chose à cet enfant.
Est-ce que je tiens compte de ces besoins,
de ces particularités ?
Et si ces particularités
étaient un point fort
sur lequel je peux m’appuyer
pour lui proposer autrement ?
Forte de ces constats et questionnements,
c’est en 2005 qu’avec Anne,
ma collègue enseignante spécialisée,
nous avons créé un outil
permettant aux enfants autistes
d’entrer dans la lecture.
Voilà comment.
Ce qui est difficile pour les enfants
avec lesquels nous travaillons,
c'est l'oral, la reconnaissance des sons.
Mais ce qui fonctionne souvent bien,
c’est la mémoire visuelle, la répétition,
les choses qui sont présentées
de manière concrète,
sans fioritures ni implicites
ou doubles sens.
Dans un premier temps,
nous apprenons aux enfants
à associer le son d’une voyelle,
à une couleur.
Par exemple, le A en vert.
Puis nous associons
cette couleur à un geste
qui représente une consonne,
par exemple, [pffff] pour le F.
Lorsque l’enfant trempe ses doigts
dans la peinture verte
et qu’il reproduit
ce geste sur une feuille,
une trace apparaît.
La trace de la fusion du F et du A.
FA.
La forme du F, la couleur du A.
Il découvre la syllabe FA.
En visualisant les syllabes,
en s’entraînant avec de nombreuses
activités reprenant ce principe,
on peut entrer dans
le décodage de syllabes
qui composent des mots, des phrases.
On construit du langage.
C’est ainsi que Ludo qui ne parle pas
mais sait déchiffrer des syllabes
et commence à lire des mots,
a pu lire un jour le mot « cheval »
et l’associer à l’image correspondante.
Il a compris à ce moment-là
que ces deux trucs étaient la même chose.
Je l’ai vu lorsqu’il m’a
regardé intensément.
Son regard voulait dire :
« Mais c’est ça ! ».
Si Anne et moi avions suivi
les guides établis par les normes,
nous n’aurions jamais créé cet outil.
Voilà ce que j’ai appris
grâce aux enfants qui nous ont permis
de dépasser ce que nous croyons savoir.
C’est « Affranchis-toi
du rapport à la norme
lorsqu’il limite les potentialités
et la créativité ».
Car c’est en s’affranchissant de la norme
que l’on peut découvrir de nouvelles
manières d’apprendre, de communiquer.
Comme lorsque l’on rencontre des personnes
qui s’expriment avec
d’autres outils que leur voix.
Leurs mains, par exemple,
ou des images, des dessins,
des pictogrammes
ou bien d’autres choses encore.
Tout ça s’appelle la communication
alternative et améliorée.
La CAA pour les initiés.
Ludo ne parle toujours pas oralement
mais il utilise une tablette
pour s’exprimer.
Noa aussi.
Il y a quelques semaines,
alors que je râlais à quatre pattes
en train de ramasser le pot à crayons
que je venais de faire tomber
en quittant délicatement ma veste,
j’entends dans mon dos
Noa dire avec sa tablette :
« Peux-tu m’aider à ramasser ça ? »,
qui est un message préenregistré
et qu’il n’avait encore jamais utilisé.
À ce moment-là,
j’en ai oublié tous les trombones,
les mines de crayons
et les stylos éparpillés par terre.
Noa, pour la première fois,
émettait un commentaire
sur ce qu’il était en train de voir.
Il était connecté à moi,
à la situation qu’on était
en train de vivre tous les deux
et il me l’a dit.
Ça n’a l’air de rien mais
cet épisode m’a bouleversé.
Noa ne parle pas.
Il se balance sur lui-même
en émettant des bruits bizarres.
Il donne souvent
l’impression de ne pas être là.
Mais que sait-on vraiment
de son monde intérieur ?
De ce qu’il perçoit de son environnement,
de la richesse de son monde intérieur ?
De ce qu’il aurait envie de dire ?
Valentin est venu deux,
voire trois fois par semaine
en séances d’orthophonie à mon cabinet.
Sa maman me disait souvent
qu’elle passait plus de temps
avec moi qu’avec ses copines.
Classique pour ces familles
qui courent de rendez-vous
en réunions pour leurs enfants.
Valentin venait tour à tour
accompagné de son père, de sa mère.
Même ses grands-parents
et ses oncles sont venus.
C’était une histoire de famille.
Tout le monde était impliqué.
Tout le monde soutenait
les progrès du petit Valentin.
Tout le monde était suspendu à ses lèvres,
attendant le moment
où il prononcerait son premier mot.
Je me souviens de mon émotion
quand, à six ans, en séance,
en présence de sa maman,
il l’a prononcé : « Chips ».
Je crois qu’elle et moi,
on aurait aimé qu’il dise autre chose.
Mais c’est comme ça,
c’est ce qu’il avait envie de dire.
C’est ça, la communication
alternative et améliorée.
C’est donner accès au monde
intérieur sans le restreindre
pour que la personne qui l’utilise puisse
dire ce qu’elle a envie de dire vraiment
et pas ce que nous aimerions qu’elle dise.
Pour qu’elle puisse prendre conscience
qu’elle a le pouvoir
d’agir sur sa propre vie,
qu’elle puisse faire
ses choix pour elle-même.
Ce que Noa et Valentin m’ont appris,
c’est : « Dépasse tes préjugés,
présume des compétences
et envisage que tout est possible ».
Alors, voilà,
si je me présente à vous ce soir,
ce n’est pas pour vous faire la morale,
ni pour être le porte-drapeau de l’autisme
ou de la communication
alternative et améliorée.
Ce serait malvenu et inapproprié.
D'autres personnes seraient
plus à même de le faire.
Des familles, des personnes autistes
qui viendraient témoigner
de leur propre monde intérieur.
Non.
Moi, je suis juste ici, comme vous,
avec mes tripes, mes colères, mes peurs,
mes doutes, mes questionnements.
Est-ce que malgré ces rencontres,
malgré ces expériences,
est-ce que je ne suis finalement pas
moi-même une partie du problème ?
Est-ce que mes représentations,
ce que je crois savoir
de telle ou telle personne,
n’est pas un facteur limitant
à sa participation sociale ?
Est-ce que j’ai vraiment donné à Yanis
toutes les opportunités possibles
pour qu’il puisse s’épanouir
et vivre la vie qu’il souhaite ?
Lui seul le saurait.
Il n’est plus là pour en témoigner.
Je me demande si j’ai été
un bon compagnon de route pour Yanis.
Mais lui a été déterminant
pour la construction
de la personne que je suis.
C'est bien ce que je vous souhaite.
Avoir la chance de rencontrer votre Yanis
ou votre Valentin.
(Applaudissements)